[Musique]
vous me connaissez sûrement on s'est
peut-être déjà croisés si si on sait
déjà croisés j'en suis sûr
mais comme je fais tout pour être
discret
[Musique]
je suis votre livreur de sushis
je suis la nounou gigard de vos enfants
ou peut-être ceux d'une de vos amis
je suis le menuisier qui fabrique vos
armoires vos portes
votre parquet
il
je suis votre manucure
j'aime quand vous vous sentez jolie et
que c'est un peu grâce à moi
[Musique]
je suis ouvrier sur le chantier en bas
de chez vous désolé pour la poussière et
le bruit
dans ce pays qui compte 66 millions
d'habitants nous serions 500 milles pour
nous appelle les travailleurs sans
papiers les migrants économiques les
clandestins nous n'avons pas fui la
guerre
alors pour l'administration nous sommes
ce qu'il faut expulser en priorité
aujourd'hui malgré les risques nous
sommes cinq à prendre la parole sans
nous cacher pour vous raconter tout
simplement pourquoi nous sommes là et
quels sont nos vies
[Musique]
m
je fais les tâches les plus durs à
savoir la démolition le marteau piqueur
la démolition avec la menace pas les
hommages pioche des poteaux des poutres
et des dalles de plancher avec le
marteau piqueur je tremble tout le
moment toute la journée pendant huit
heures et vous rentrez chez vous vous
donnez à peine il ya tout le corps qui
vous fait mal et vous êtes sûr encore
que vous allez reprendre l'allemand la
même chose si vous passez devant un
chantier de démolition et que vous voyez
un mec avec le mans piqueur
soyez sûr que s'agit d'un sans papiers
ne vous posez pas la question parce que
c'est le travail d'esclave
[Musique]
je m'appelle phoebe
je 40 ans
[Musique]
je suis arrivée du sénégal il ya sept
ans
[Musique]
il tient pas compte de la valeur des
sans papiers parce que on ne tient pas
compte de leur santé on ne les protège
pas comment protègera ceux qui sont en
règle
parce qu'il ya des murs qu'on vous
demande vient de mourir et il ya au
moins une chance sur deux d'être arrêtés
mais ont exposé par refuser quoi que le
boulot à cause d'un bug ou non contracté
une maladie bien d'autres importants
j'ai pas encore sonné j'ai pas le choix
mais je joue si cela fait quatre ans et
demi que je suis livreur de sushis c'est
un travail très pénible parce que je
travaille 7 jours sur 7 pour 7h30 de
leur ire faucha je n'ai jamais de congé
même le 25 décembre
tout le monde fait la fête et moi je
dois travailler encore plus vrai pour le
1er mai la fête des ouvriers je n'ai
jamais deux jours de repos et si j'ai un
accident sur la route et que je ne peux
pas venir travailler ou que je suis
simplement malade je ne suis pas payé
[Musique]
je m'appelle rahmane
j'ai 49 ans rôle
ah ouais je suis arrivée du bangladesh
il ya cinq ans au début pour apprendre
le métier je me mettais à l'arrière du
scooter d'un collègue pour qu'il me
montre comment faire
moi je notais toutes les adresses et
toutes les rues sur un cahier et la nuit
quand je rentre chez moi je révisais
pour m'orienter c'est très difficile car
il n'y a aucun rapport entre le bengali
et le français pourtant j'ai pris des
cours de français mais au bout d'un
moment il a fallu que j'y renonce
il fallait que je donne la priorité à
mon travail le salaire que je gagne
parfois ceux où blake et parfois se
déclarer
comment c'est possible d'être déclaré
quand on est sans papiers je viens avec
le pkk
un frère un cousin un ami qui comme les
prête parce qu'il vit la règle moi je ne
suis pas mais que je veux quand même
travailler je vais respecter dans une
boîte d'intérim les présente là-bas
d'intérim voit bien que c'est pas moi
qui figure sur la pérennité mais bon
puisque ça l'arrangé et que ça fait
avancer son travail la ferme les yeux
[Musique]
oh
d'enrôlement les cas manquer moi c'est
mon patron qui m'a conseillé lui
apporter les papiers d'un ami il m'a dit
que si je ne lui présentait pas les
papiers d'une autre personne
il ne pouvait pas me faire travailler le
système économique de la france est fait
de telle manière que beaucoup
d'employeurs font travailler des
personnes sans papiers
j'ai des fiches de paie qui ne sont pas
un moment tant qu indirectement je
cotise à la sécu au chômage à la
retraite auxquels j'ai même pas droit
[Musique]
et vous avez autre chose c'est que j'ai
pu aussi des impôts par exemple en
gagnant 1000 euros par mois je donne 150
euros à la liesse pour que lui à son
tour bus pc1 pour la fin de l'année
ça veut dire que je paie mes impôts mais
de manière indirecte
quand on travaille sous alias on est
parfois trois ou quatre personnes a
travaillé sur la nouvelle entité et que
ça fait des cotisations de 3 à 4
personnes qui rentrent dans les caisses
de l'urssaf à la fin de chaque mois mais
puisqu'il s'agit de rentrées d'argent
l'urssaf fermer les yeux c'est un peu
l'eldorado pour eux quoi
[Musique]
maintenant ça va mieux mais au début ça
a été super dur
je travaille chez une assistante
maternelle qui pourrait dire des dix
enfants par jour et c'est moi qui
m'occupais des enfants qui donnait à
manger qui l'échangé qui le donnait de
soins je travaillais de 9h à 18h pour 30
euros par jour
[Musique]
je m'appelle fanni j'ai 33 ans en france
depuis 12 ans je viens de la côte
d'ivoire
j'ai aussi fait la plonge dans un
restaurant italien mais après je me suis
retrouvé à faire le ménage à faire
dessert affaires salade et soit le
moteur sur les trucs sur l'escalier pour
même le plafond la ville plafond et
voilà je commençais de 10h à 23h et gtp
900 euros est soi même il ne donne pas
tout l'argent ou donner 500 euros et
blanc ne me donnait l'argent parlent pas
tous quoi je vais fermer ma bouche parce
qu'il sait que j'ai pas de papiers voulu
aussi il me dit oui je te dis seulement
qu'il n'est pas la main c'est moi que
pour lui c'est il me rendre service
parce que il s'est dit que non j'ai pas
droite m'a donné un papier
jean todt à me remercier
pendant trois ans et elle en fait de
l'exploitation et là on m'avait déjà des
faux papiers mais je voulais pas le
faire mais après comme j'étais beaucoup
exploité genou 10,6 et sa part que silva
pile il le faut et on ne considère
normalement c'est pas le but de
l'arnaqué ou fait du mal ou lui c'est
vrai comment c'est
mais c'était nécessaire pour être vivre
dignement ou être couverts comme les
autres quoi
[Musique]
personne n'est né avec une étiquette est
institué autour du cou pourquoi on tient
compte plus que du peuple du papier que
de la personne humaine que sa valeur
on
[Musique]
je m'appelle armand tôt jeu 20 ans
il y a quatre ont tout seul je suis
partie d'albanie
[Musique]
je suis arrivé ici à 16 ans je parlais
pas du tout français
en fait comment j'étais mineurs isolés
étrangers en fait j'étais pris en charge
par là par le services sociaux
[Musique]
j'étais placé dans collège en 4e 4e
général avait pas d'étrangers coincés là
je me disais j'avais un chance peut-être
pour apprendre le français plus vite
possible
c'était c'était mon but en j'avais là
j'avais la rage contre moi pour
apprendre pour que je mentais pour les
gens il puisse dire oui lui s'est
intégrée et peu voilà à l'école quand
j'avais des cours de français la prime
ou le matin un jour le prof de français
ils nos amis johnny hallyday a allumé le
feu il commence à dire ouais ça c'est du
bon français ça c'est des vrais de vrai
mais j'ai trouvé ça joli chanson j'ai
bien aimé après voilà j'écouterai pas
tous les jours on ne peut en cinq mois
je peux je comprends le coup
parfaitement le français en ans je parle
je parle est correctement comment je
parle aujourd'hui
[Musique]
enfin première année de saint pée mon
profil m'a proposé de passer le concours
de meilleur apprenti de france sans
concours très prestigieux qui met le
métier en valeur qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui kiffent honte aux concours mais
ils sont pas il y en a pas beaucoup qui
sont élus grosse pression se brisent des
fois j'avais du mal à dormir
finalement mon prof
il m'a appelé il m'a dit décroché la
médaille d'or nationale
je me suis dit c'est un concours qui est
reconnu par la république française soit
c'était un truc incroyable qui m'arrive
sauf que je mets mes 18 ans c'est là en
fait que tout bascule
jusqu'à un an de 18 ans on est
accompagné par les services sociaux
après les nôtres 18 en bas on devient
quelqu'un indésirables
[Musique]
j'ai reçu une obligation de quitter
territoire français les phrases en fait
qu'ils n'ont plus choqué c'était
considérons que le parcours de ce
collier à man 2 ne permet pas de faire
état de son intégration de sa motivation
et de son insertion dans la société
française l'intéressé est obligé de
quitter les territoires français dans
les délais de 30 jours à compter de la
notification du présent arrêt
j'avais la rage je comprenais pas
j'étais choqué je me suis dit il faut
faire croire pour que pour que je me
fasse accepter c'est en fait ça là là
j'entends dans le on peut dire dans la
clandestinité ce que c'était son papy
quoi c'est de jour au lendemain je
pouvais plus aller au cinéma avec mon
petit ami ne soit comment je faisais
parfois ou quand je pouvais aller
courrier a souvent j'aimais bien
gouailleur quand on les sent pas plus on
ne peut pas vivre normalement c'est à
dire on a toujours cette peur au ventre
moi quand je sors de chez moi je me mets
à l'esprit que textile était de sortie
mais s'est dit ils veulent pas retourner
sur toi parce que j'ai toujours peur
j'ai toujours peur de la police je me
dis que s'il ya pas il ya un sirènes de
police qui hurle je sursaute automatique
magie
j'ai peur quand je dis techs et sailor
quoi tu as toujours ça à l'esprit que
qantas a pas tué c'est un conte cherche
c'est un conte cherche
là
pour éviter les contrôles de police
je ne vais jamais dans les grandes
stations de métro je ne vais jamais dans
les aéroports si je n'ai pas quelque
chose d'important à faire je ne sors pas
le pire moment c'est quand j'ai reçu
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
français pour ne plus avoir à prendre le
bus ou le métro
à ce moment là j'ai pris la décision de
déménager près de mon travail
on était six mêmes huit personnes dans
une chambre de 12 mètres carrés
il y avait trois lits superposés avec 6
personnes et deux autres qui dormaient
dans le couloir c'était horrible
pour ça je payais 200 euros par mois
c'est drôle alors c'était ça le bruyant
il n'y avait pas d'air quand on est sans
papiers
tout le monde cherche à vous exploiter
votre employeur est votre logeur mais on
n'a pas le choix
[Musique]
oh
mais quand on n'a pas de papiers on a
toujours très peur
water m à moi je serai emma j'ai 59 ans
cela fait déjà dix ans que je suis venu
de chine avec l'une de mes filles
même au travail dès qu'une cliente qui
te saluent nous aussi on sort vite on
n'ose pas rester de peur que les
policiers viennent d'effectuer un
contrôle alors qu'il vente qu'il pleuve
ont fait les cent pas dans la rue mais
on se cache touche à ceux comme au petit
sourire mais moi ça tfc la traite des
vaches et une cliente revient nous
rentrons de nouveau avec un grand
sourire qui auraient envie de payer sans
un sourire et même si notre coeur saigne
devant la cliente
nous devons toujours avoir l'air heureux
et lui demander ça va tu vas bien chez
nous et ses locaux la leçon il faut la
soul est clair
amusé casse-cou les j'écrase échange mon
travail est carrément risqué pour un
sans papier mes collègues qui sont en
règle
quand il y a beaucoup de commandes et
qu'il faut aller vite par exemple le
week-end eux ils passent au feu orange
l'employeur veut que j'aille vite lui
mais moi je ne veux pas si la police
m'arrête je peux aller au commissariat
et être renvoyée au bangladesh
et là le patron ce n'est plus son
problème ici je vis comme si j'avais
commis un crime
toujours à me cacher de la police mais
ce sont les criminels qui se cachent de
la police moi je n'ai commis aucun crime
et pourtant je me tiens à l'écart de la
police
[Musique]
d'être femme sans papiers a toujours des
fois où des hommes qui savent que vous
n'avez pas de papiers qui savent que
peut il peut profiter des deux vous
restera le commis cuisinier tout en mars
elle est souvent il vient et qu'en y
repensant il reste à gauche à droite des
900 cru que il monte il monte on sait
que les patrons ils venaient mais xavier
et moi en attendant moi je vais dire
mais je n'arrive pas je vais appeler la
police mais ce que je peux appeler la
police
au menu
c'est d'autant plus difficile pour une
femme que vous ne comprenez pas la
langue française ni la culture les
voyons le savent et donc vous devenez un
cadeau pour un soir à 22h le patron m'a
dit que j'avais fini mon travail
il m'a montré l'arrêt de bus et m'a dit
d'attendre là je ne parle pas le
français il fallait attendre 45 minutes
avant qu'un bus passe sous mes [ __ ] et
plus ils sont alors j'ai décidé de
marcher j'ai marché plusieurs heures et
j'ai fini par apercevoir un tunnel qui
ressemblait au métro quelqu'un faisait
le ménage et la grille était fermé
j'ai demandé métro métro je crois qu'il
a compris il m'a répondu c'est ici le
métro alors il a pris ma main
il a ouvert une porte il m'a fait entrer
dans l'âge est là il s'est jeté sur moi
il a commencé à me toucher à m'embrasser
je disais non je n'arrêtais pas de
tourner la tête à un moment j'ai aperçu
une pelle
j'ai voulu la prendre pour le frapper
l'homme a vu et a mis sa main sur ma
bouche je continue à crier non je pense
qu'il a eu peur
alors il m'a lâché à mon retour
n'arrêtait pas de pleurer ma fille m'a
demandé ce qui s'était passé j'ai
simplement répondu
maman est très fatiguée pendant très
longtemps j'ai gardé ce secret pour moi
[Musique]
oui longo à l'époque engine
on avait le droit d'avoir qu'un seul
enfant j'en ai eu trois donc j'étais
hors la loi à cause de ça j'ai été
licencié et le magasin de mon mari a été
fermé mais deuxième et troisième enfant
était comme des clandestins
il n'avait pas d'état civil pour qu'ils
aient une existence administrative
il a fallu que je paye des pots de vin
très élevé pourquoi j'ai eu trois
enfants
d'abord parce que j'aime les enfants ça
mais c'est aussi parce que j'ai eut
d'abord deux filles et en chine c'est
comme ça il faut avoir un fils si tu ne
veux pas que ton mari divorce pour
élever mes trois enfants
ça a été très dur j'ai fait plein de
petits boulots qu'un cireuse de
chaussures dans la rue j'ai aussi ouvert
un petit restaurant ambulant en chine il
est interdit de faire la cuisine dans la
rue un jour les autorités sont venus et
ils ont détruit mon chariot
je les ai suppliés en leur disant que
c'était pour nourrir mes enfants ils
m'ont répondu que c'était interdit
et ils sont partis avec
je viens de côte d'ivoire je suis issu
d'une famille de sept enfants est avec
cinq filles et deux garçons et ça n'a
pas été facile pour nous tous les jours
on ne mangeait pas à notre faim ça
revient deux jours que je mangeais pas
dans une visée misère mais a même pas eu
peur
il y avait de l'amour il y avait
concentré
moi j'étais obligé à 14 ans présent à
fait à manger pour mes trois frères et
soeurs et je ne pouvais pas jouer comme
tout le monde je vais comme j'étais déjà
une grande
[Musique]
je fuis mon pays de l'albanie
malheureusement mon père était décédé
quand j'avais 6 ans ça a rendu la vie
plus difficile que le maire est obligé
travailler pour nourrir des enfants elle
travaillait dans un supermarché souvent
arranger des rayons étaient dans la
caisse et gagner 150 euros par mois pour
nourrir deux enfants est côté en plus
est d'avis et ai été un peu chez elle en
avait du mal je veux un but du sénégal
sud une famille modeste famille de
quatre frères et de traces de casseurs
je suis le seul de ma famille avait vu
le bac le seul de mon village à la pop a
valu le bac c'est une fierté pour moi
personnellement mais aussi une fierté
pour mon père quatre imams et pour ma
pomme envoyer à l'école
c'est après que j'ai poursuivi mes
études supérieures à l'université de
dakar c'était des études de quoi le
philosophie j'aimais beaucoup la figure
parce que je voyais que c'était une
c'est un domaine dans lequel il ya
beaucoup de réflexions autour de sujets
qui nous concernent personnellement qui
concerne la société ce qui concerne le
monde qui concerne tout le monde qu il
ya par le domaine où la philosophie une
passerelle ne repasse quoi donc c'était
une matière à réflexion malheureusement
j'ai dû abandonner mes études on n'avait
pas les moyens d'acheter les livres
qu'il fallait acheter
quand j'ai abandonné j'ai fait des
recherches et du travail non je ne sais
pas du tout gagné comme bien maigre
salaire j'ai gagné 100 euros le mois
pendant cinq ans
[Musique]
je me suis marié en 2000 j'ai eu trois
enfants deux garçons et une fille
en fait le déclic c'était juste en 2005
où mon fils souffrait d'une hernie qu'il
fallait opérer et jusqu'à geler
transporté à l'hôpital on m'a dressé une
liste vraiment de ce que je devais
acheter et que moi je parvenais jeune je
ne parvenais pas à le faire
intérieurement ça me faisait faisais moi
parce que j'étais un fonctionnaire qui
travailler mais qui ne pouvait pas
parvenir à la résoudre ses propres
problèmes
alors j'ai tenté quoi j'ai dit banco du
kit vous cherchez ailleurs
par ailleurs avec nos petit bagage
culturel qui pourrait peut-être réussi
quelque chose de grandiose quand
dominique de meyer au départ est marrant
c'est que définis à ma place et elle est
tombée malade
la famille et m'a dit comme états
seraient tombées malades et c'est tant
que la partie à sa place à jeter dans
plusieurs mélange d'émotions la
structure et la tristesse l'angoissent
et la peine pour ma soeur et c'est au
fur et à mesure que je me suis dit oui
c'est à partir d'asie
il faut il faut s'armer
psychologiquement il faut aller en
france
mon mari ne m'aidait pas bien au
contraire il était tombé dans la drogue
il était devenu violent et il me
frappait j'ai donc décidé que je voulais
quitter la chine pendant dix ans j'ai
économisé mais j'ai surtout empreinte il
beaucoup d'argent pour venir avec ma
fille cadette
c'est par un passeur que ça c'est fait
pour deux visages il nous a pris trente
mille euros
cette somme nous l'avons emprunté en
grande partie un usurier si on ne paient
pas ils nous menaçaient je vais tuer les
membres de ta famille
je vais tuer ton petit frère ils savent
qui fait partie de ta famille car elle
s'est portée garante
à 16 ans j'ai décidé de partir ce que
j'en pouvais plus ça s'est fait par par
des connaissances
j'avais parlé à mon frère j'ai dit que
je parte à l'étranger on a trouvé un
passeur
c'est ce qui m'arrive allait faire un
prix d'ami parce que ce qu'il a vu que
j'étais j'ai des petits tours et j'avais
peu à peu près 500 600 euros pour partir
[Musique]
d
au bangladesh
j'étais un joueur d'échecs très connu
j'avais l'habitude de voyager pour
participer à des tournois nationaux et
même internationaux
j'ai gagné plein de médailles et de prix
du coup j'ai pensé
le prochain grand tournoi d'échecs va
bientôt avoir lieu en espagne
je me suis inscrit et c'est comme ça que
j'ai obtenues légalement mon visa pour
le rendre au bangladesh
j'avais ma propre maison une grande
maison sur deux étages
financièrement on était plutôt à l'aise
parce qu'en plus on avait beaucoup de
terre qui donnait de belles récoltes
avec ma femme et ma fille c'était le
bonheur de temps en temps on allait se
promener en famille on allait à la mer
se baigner à l'époque grâce à mes études
supérieures de chimiques
j'avais un bon travail dans une usine de
sucre mais j'étais aussi membre du parti
d'opposition au bangladesh
le bnp à l' usine où je travaillais les
ouvriers étaient exploités alors avec
eux j'ai organisé une grande
manifestation
vous savez le bangladesh n'est pas une
véritable démocratie la liberté
d'expression n'existe pas soudain
pendant la manifestation
notre cortège a été attaqué par un
groupe de voyous et par la police ils
ont tiré sur nous il ya eu beaucoup de
blessés et de morts alors les autorités
ont lancé un mandat d'arrêt contre moi
ils ont prétendu que j'étais responsable
de ces morts j'ai eu peur car ils ont
arrêté des amis à moi et ils les ont
exécutés
quand j'ai appris cette nouvelle je me
suis dit s'il me retrouve
ils me tueront moi aussi
pourquoi nous sommes venus en france
parce qu'ici les femmes sont considérées
comme des personnes à part entière elles
ont même le droit de fumer dans la rue
de porter des minijupes et des petits os
je me disais ah c'est vraiment bien ça
en france c'est un tout un pays derrière
c'est un mythe samatan cramer pour nom
qui avoue n'avoir jamais été en france a
souvent joué des copains qui partent à
l'étranger qui revenait son nouveau
nouveau luc on peut dire à nouveau style
et c'est à dire il était habillé il est
habillé à l'italienne en vendée et
c'était basse à nous attirer souvent des
excités c'est toujours mieux là-bas que
là on va tout le monde voulait essayer
de partir pour essayer pour foncer dans
la vie après que vous devez écouter
c'est vous croyez que c'est facile ce
n'est pas du tout ce que vous pensez
c'est au contraire plus difficile que
ces mêmes mais puisqu'on veut y aller on
se moque parfois les enfants suivent pas
on ne croit pas à ce que 10 ans toute
façon ils sont et s'habille mieux que
non ils n'osent le famille mieux que
nous dans ça veut dire que disent pas la
vérité constat les mains mais bon c'est
ça aussi il faut découvrir la vérité
pour le savoir
pour
c'était la nuit quand je quand je suis
parti j'en ai pas parlé à ma mère parce
que d'un côté je voulais pas la blesser
je savais sa réaction c'est voulait pas
que je parle parce que j'étais sont les
petits gamins aussi deux derniers que un
peu le petit chouchou 23 heures on
arrive devant le camion et tout cela je
suis dit c'est bon ça y est ça c'est le
départ et j'étais aux voix comme ça et
je parte pour monter dans un camion
allemand familles attendent quelque
chose à donner c'est là qu'ils qui
sortent sans portefeuille qui m'avait
qui m'a donné
il avait il avait des sous il y avait la
photo de mon père c'est là en fait
j'avais je commençais un peu à craquer
dans les côtes et j'avais un peu l'art
aux yeux parce que je sais dit seulement
je veux partir je veux quitter ma
famille là-bas je personne je vais le
camion qui démarre et c'est là que que
je retourne la tête pour voir mon frère
pour dire ouais c'est c'était là le
moment est plus dur de voir mon frère
parce qu'il avait aussi les larmes aux
yeux de voir son petit frère partir
comme ça dans l'inconnu quoi c'était
avec ma fille cadette
nous sommes partis le 22 décembre 2006
mes deux autres enfants nous ont
accompagnés je leur ai dit maman part
mais je ne sais pas quand est-ce que je
vais pouvoir revenir
je vous demande de prendre bien soin de
vous
le jour du départ je me suis réveillé
j'ai regardé mes enfants qui dormaient
encore et j'avais l'impression que je
vais regarder pour la dernière fois moi
je n'ai même pas pu prévenir ma femme et
ma fille de mon départ je n'ai appelé
personne je craignais d'être sur écoute
d'être surveillés j'avais peur de tout
il fallait que je quitte le pays le plus
discrètement possible que moubarak est
en cours
bon ça que j'ai mis mes affaires qui
allait servir que sont importantes pour
moi nouvelle vie il y avait mes diplômes
notamment le bec
j'ai vu les photos de mes enfants ma
femme mes parents mais aussi j'avais une
bague que mon père m'avait offerte
j'ai l'image de mon père tout le temps
qui me vient et qui me dit mais toujours
soit déterminée et de l'abnégation dans
ce que tu fais travail pour survivre
mais ne fais jamais des bêtises même
après maman elle me donnait des conseils
comme d'habitude voilà il faut pas avoir
fait la débauche fois les travailler vos
fautes s'agissait dit été sage mais
voilà je dédierai dit en quoi parce que
c'est un pays étranger voilà même de
bénédiction car comment l'africaine que
dieu parce que ça marche pour toi que
les plaines bénédiction voilà qui
t'accompagne j'ai mis dans mon sac au
moins les départs
il nous reste de ma mère une robe de
prier que qu'elle priait là dedans
elle avait le don de ma mère ce conseil
c'est comme si elle était quelque part à
côté de moi j'ai aussi pris la photo de
ma mère et ma soeur et moi tiens ma
place et malheureusement elle est tombée
malade donc sa faute à elle aussi
j'avais ça sont peut-être est très
proche donc lui voilà moi les photos que
j'avais emporté de mes enfants je ne les
ai pas gardé longtemps à paris nous
vivions à 8 dans un dortoir de 8 mètres
carrés
c'est là que j'avais rangé mes valises
un jour nous sommes rentrés du travail
l'appartement avait été retourné la
valise dans laquelle je gardais mes
photos avaient été volés quand je
regardais ses photos j'avais
l'impression que mes enfants étaient à
mes côtés sans ces photos c'est comme si
je les avais perdu
où
[Musique]
vous savez quand j'étais jeune j'avais
deux patients en fait la philosophie
l'achitecture c'est pourquoi quand j'ai
débarqué en france c'était pour
poursuivre mes études
parce que j'avais quand même la capacité
de le faire interdire quoi je veux dire
mais que quand les universités - fermé
la porte
elles perdent pas que j'avais pas de
papiers je me suis pas découragé pour
autant j'ai voulu suivre coûte que coûte
cette formation là c'est pourquoi j'ai
contacté une école pour pour faire une
formation en ligne très coûteuse
d'ailleurs d'information elle m'a coûté
3000 euros est intacte sans papiers
c'était 400 personnes suicidaires pour
moi mais l'abnégation la détermination
je suis pas roulé en f1 et je lui le
diplôme
aujourd'hui je vais mais c'est un truc
qui ne sert à rien pour le moment parce
que je suis sans papiers ma plus grande
blessure c'est quand ma demande d'asile
a été refusée ici que j'étais un grand
joueur d'échecs et même que j'étais
célèbre là bas ils l'ont cru que j'étais
impliqué dans la politique ça aussi ils
ont cru mais que ma vie était menacée à
cause de mes activités politiques
ils ne l'ont pas cru
[Musique]
j'étais dévastée j'étais tellement sûr
qu'ils allaient accorder l'asile
je n'ai pas dormi durant des nuits je
faisais des cauchemars je devenais fou
je me coupais plus les cheveux je ne me
rase et plus la barbe jeunes appelés
plus personne
même ma femme et ma fille je ne leur ai
pas dit tout de suite car en l'apprenant
réseau aurait été triste et inquiète
elle aussi avait beaucoup d'espoir
[Musique]
allô mon amour mon amour mais toi quand
est ce que tu viens quand est-ce que je
viens c'est bientôt je serai là très
bientôt tu dis toujours ça inch'allah
j'arrive bientôt je fais le maximum
ok merci ma chérie tu me passes ta maman
s'il te plaît à l'eau comment ça va
[Musique]
tout le monde me demande de tes
nouvelles
il se demande ce qui se passe à huy qui
vous qu'est-ce que tu le répond qu'est
ce que je peux répondre comme tu ne peux
pas revenir
il me demande pourquoi tu ne nous emmène
pas auprès de toi pour qu'on ne se
retrouve pas quelque part tu sais qu'il
faut que j'attende d'avoir des papiers
tout il faut qu'on soit patient tous les
deux buts
bon il faut que je te laisse une chance
vous me manquez la vie je vous aime ta
té prenez soin de vous
ça fait presque cinq ans qu'on a les
mêmes conversation et que je leur dis
qu'on va se retrouver ou qu'elles vont
pouvoir me rejoindre couper le son mais
comme je répète la même chose
et depuis si longtemps elle ne me
croient plus elle pense que je ne fais
pas ce qu'il faut ou que je mens tu ne
sais pas combien de temps je vais
pouvoir tenir encore dans cette
situation mais j'essaye de leur donner
des messages d'espoir et je leur demande
d'y croire sans espoir aucun élu comment
je peux vivre
[Musique]
une seule fois j'ai vu ma fille par
skype
c'était quand elle avait quatre en cinq
ans alors que cage l'a quittée elle
avait que cinq mois elle se demandait
tout ça derrière lui qui était si la qui
j'étais avec poils quoi ce que c'était à
son père qui quand il entend parler
voilà c'est la première fois qu'ils me
voyaient mois ci la première fois que je
lui parlais et moi je peux pas aller la
voir elle a inséré dans mes bras allait
faire tout ce qu'il faut apporter tout
ce dont elle a besoin pour lui démontrer
que leur insu sans peur mais alors ok
moi ça fait cinq ans que je n'ai pas
touché ma femme
cinq ans que je n'ai pas caresser le
visage de ma fille cinq ans c'est long
les cheveux de ma femme sensible ou si
l'on j'aimais tant l'écart et c'est ma
femme avec qui j'avais une relation si
romantique
aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus que de
lointains souvenirs comme des vieux rêve
parce que maintenant sur skype
on ne parle que des problèmes toujours
et encore des problèmes
par exemple au bangladesh
sans un homme la vie est très difficile
pour les femmes comme la mienne est
jeune et jolie comme ma fille d'ailleurs
cherche son dos elle a peur ' chauve
souris car les tout le temps victime de
harcèlement sexuel
tapi dans le train dans le bus dans la
rue stats et du coup comme je ne reviens
pas ses copines lui conseille de refaire
sa vie et de trouver un nouveau mari
perdre un proche et de ne pas être là
pour les raisons du papier ça c'est un
blessé qui composent qu'on n'oublie
jamais moi ça m'est arrivé quand j'ai
perdu ma grande soeur améliorée a mis ma
confidente et que j'ai pas pu aller la
voir quand elle était malade et même
aller à cette ligne rennes moi ça me
blesse c'est que moi je pense pas la
cicatrice est quoi
[Musique]
pourquoi vous ne rentrez pas au sénégal
je ne peux pas retourner au sénégal
à l'heure actuelle cela des puces à
temps c'est pas c'est pas rien quoi et
que j'ai travaillé pendant tout le temps
j'ai fourni de l'effort
je me suis battu aussi pour mon
intégration
rentré comme ça au bredouille
c'est un code sorte une certaine un
certain échec est le seul du mac comme
pourra éprouver ce sentiment de 5 min
moi j'adorais rentrer au bangladesh
auprès de ma femme et de ma fille sur
mes terres avec mes amis là bas j'ai
tout juste pourquoi je voudrais rester
récit ma situation est désastreuse
je suis au bas de l'échelle c'est comme
si j'étais à la rue si le bangladesh
devient une vraie démocratie et que je
ne suis plus poursuivi alors oui je
rentrerai dans mon pays avec plaisir moi
je suis là depuis dix ans oui je
pourrais retourner en chine mais j'aime
tellement plus la france ni je suis là
depuis si longtemps et surtout ça y est
nous avons enfin rembourser la mafia ça
nous a pris sept ans son humour one shna
jeu merci chez sur lentilly
ça fait 12 ans que je suis en france je
suis je suis comme une phrase est de
même sujet par la sonorité française
j'ai adopté la france que voilà et j'ai
envie d'y rester
quand la france pleure je pleure avec la
france car la lapandry jerry avec la
france
voilà la france avait des malheurs le
mois de janvier charlie hebdo toute la
journée et je parie que de pleurer
jallet a pas de république très très
innovant mais aussi pareil j'allais
prendre de photos trail au bataclan émis
des bougies g j'ai compati à la
tristesse et la joie
j'aimerais bien posé mes valises parce
qu'il ya ça fait 80 me que je suis en
france
le rêve le plus grand que je voulais que
je sois français et que je puisse faire
ma vie tranquillement vote
toi tu veut carrément la nationalité
française ouais j'aimerais bien pourquoi
médecins français d'un côté oui parce
que je peux ce participant fait à la vie
française
je participe de la société comme tout le
monde quoi se soigner
ce que j'aime le plus ici ma nature
c'est l'égalité et la liberté
nous sommes tous égaux ici j'ai le droit
de m'exprimer autant que le président de
la république c'est pour ça que je n'ai
pas peur de parler
la liberté en france c'est justement ça
la nuit de quoi vous rêvez je rêve de me
retrouver enfin en tant que ces dix
appelé enfin en taxi dit moi je suis
appelé kalidou je me suis fait appeler
gladio je me suis peut appeler esmael
vivre sous allez hop c'est pas une vie à
part dans l'identité aussi on perd tout
nous allons donc les bourses si vous
croisez des compatriotes à moi qui vend
des dvd à la sauvette ou des fleurs ou
qui livrent des sushis dites vous qu ils
ont peut-être la même histoire que moi
alors s'il vous plaît regard des mots
comme des êtres humains
et de parler à visage découvert parce
que je suis un être humain qui cherche à
vivre dans la dignité et vivre ce n'est
pas que de respirer ou d'inspirer vivre
se garde sa dignité la dignité ne se
regarde pas comme ça elle se garde avec
une lutte farouche contre tout ce qui
réduit l'homme a le fera rage
à ce qu'ils ont peur des étrangers et
j'espère qu'ils n'ont pas peur de moi ou
de nom
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]